allahar ASU
[Silence]
Ash
as muham
Asam
[Silence]
Sal
he
[Silence]
allahar
acar ill
[Silence]
alhamdulillah alham
sub
[Silence]
was
my dear brothers respected
Elders beloved youth mother and sisters
we thank Allah subhana tala for keeping
us alive one more day on the path of
Islam on the and allowing me and you to
enter his house and allow us to worship
him in the manner that pleases him I ask
Allah subhana accept from me and accept
from you that little we on his path a
mean and I bear witness there is no
deity worthy of worship except for Allah
subhana tala and Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi am is his last and
final messenger for surely who Allah
subhana tala chooses to guide misguide
and you were choose to misguide guide
him back to the path and we seek refuge
in Allah from darkness of ourselves and
evil of our Deeds for Allah is all
knowing and all seeing what his creation
does today for the I I have I have a
hard task to to to address you guys and
it's a hard task in sense that anytime
that we try
to have
a or transliteration of the Quran it's a
hard job
Indeed but before we get to the Ayah
that I wanted to talk about I want to I
want to talk about why we will discuss
the Ayah by presenting you the the the
pretext to the context that we'll
discuss
today so first and foremost
we all have
seen the
atrocities and the
hardships and the Bloodshed that has
been committed and being committed for
over the past year and if anything
else every single prediction of when it
will end and how it will end has gone
out the window if anything it has
increased many folds over and if you pay
attention
it is not just what's happening in Gazza
in West Bank and the fistin itself it's
what's happening in Lebanon what's
happening in Sudan what's happening in
China with the ringas what's happening
in Burma and all of those things that
has been done to
Muslims and a common question a Muslim
might have is
why when we are a believing people we
believe in Allah Allah subhana taala we
are monotheistic we worship Allah
subhana tala why does this continue to
happen or the question might come that
Allah subhana taala has 99 attributes
that he has
listed right he
is he has all of those attributes listed
and when we want to seek Allah's help or
Aid we seek it through one of those
attributes that it's related to him when
we're seeking his Mercy we call
out and when we want him to protect us
we call out
Yak so this attribute of Allah subhah wa
ta'ala we're calling out and we see
nothing
happening at least in our mindsets
nothing is happening
and the question is why is it
happening so one of the suras in one of
the AY Allah subhana tala best addresses
his attribute
of
is now the attribute itself is not
listed in the Ayah so don't be confused
but Allah subh mentions in the Ayah 73
and he starts
off all people
he addresses just the general
audience he does not
say or he doesn't
say he doesn't
say he says
yeah and then something amazing happens
is that Allah subhana tala removes
himself out of
that a by
saying he says an example has been
given so pay attention to
it because the condition is that today
unfortunately when we are talking and
communicating with people on different
subjects regarding our Dean and as soon
as you say Allah subh says in the Quran
says that oh
man now I have to listen to another
lecture from thisy
or you say Allah says come on man
what what what no no I don't want to
lecture from you I don't want to hear it
so Allah subhana literally is in the
Ayah
saying Hey listen pay
attention you're a you're a person yes
I'm a person pay attention there is an
example that was given listen to it he
doesn't say Allah is giving the example
he doesn't say wasallam is giving the
example he say mus gave an example he
says an example is been given to you
it's been given to you pay
attention Okay Ya Allah what's the
example Allah
says those
people who do not invoke Allah subhana
tala who do not ask Allah subhana tala
or ask anything besides Allah subhana
tala they do not have the
ability they cannot even create a fly if
they all gather
together I hope I'm not losing you I
told you there is it's it's a hard job
for me today to go from the topic I
started with and that was the pretext
for you guys I'm giving you the context
so we understand what Allah quality
Allah's quality of alwi
means but she hold on what what is what
is this have to do with anything a fly
Allah is saying they cannot create a fly
what kind of example is this a
fly is fly a good thing no usually when
a fly comes everybody's you know shooing
it trying to kill it it's never good for
you you know it just comes Allah says
pay
attention it says if the fly they were
they were first and foremost if they
gathered all their forces they gathered
all their Technologies all their AIS
every single thing they couldn't even
create a
fly but sometimes you somebody would
come to me and say you know they have
now robots small enough that looks like
a fly so they can pollinate these trees
and stuff okay so Allah knew this was
going to happen right so he says okay
here's the next Ayah or the next line in
that Ayah we're in still same Ayah he
says if the fly came and took something
from them they can't even get it back
from
them they if the fly came and took
something from them they don't even have
the ability with all their technology to
go get that morsel of food or the food
that it took to bring it
back by the way if you if you are if you
are wanting to pay attention and and do
your research when a fly lands on the
food it doesn't just simply lick your
food there's a chemical process that
occurs when the fly comes in contact
with any food that's
available so as such even if you went
and captured the
fly you know I had a big fly in my room
and it came and sat on my my French
fries and I'm going to take my revenge
we go get the fly and I put it in the
petri dish right and I put it in their
microscope and I say okay fly where is
my where is my French fry piece that you
took you can't take it
back because when it flies sits on food
there is a chemical reaction that occurs
it puts down its saliva immediately and
the food is turned into acid so that it
can be digested with the fly and it
takes it away that's it end of the
story you can't even get it
back I want you to stay with me today I
told you it was not going to be an easy
easy easy thing to to discuss this Ayah
this Ayah can take up to two hours to
discuss I have the audacity of doing it
in less than 15
minutes but I want you to understand
what Allah subhana tala is giving us an
example
of all the powers in the world that you
can gather first and foremost can create
a fly and if it did create an arish a
fly that's fine Allah says go and take
the morsel of the food back from the fly
that took it from you bring it
back but here's something that that's
amazing that happens in the next part of
the of the of the same
Ayah Allah
says
indeed the weak indeed is the seeker and
the one that is seeking after they're
both
weak they're both
weak It's a combination of weaknesses
even if you can get it if you can can
develop all that you're still a weak
weak person that is running after
something that's
weak what does that
mean you know most of us in this room
are immigrants we have immigrated from
different lands to to to to come
here and then you know you come here
you're oh you know if I open a
business I can do this I can do this my
life will be better and I'll do this and
I'll do this and I'll do this and I'll
do this and sometimes what we're seeking
well most of the times we're seeking
it's weak
itself it's weak it's based on Economy
based on job I don't have a job tomorrow
the company's no longer there the the
thing that you were seeking all your
life doesn't exist
either and Allah is reminding you you
are weak the things you want the things
you want to achieve are also weak Within
I'll I'll share a story with you I heard
it from the person who was involved in
the story he said I used to visit New
Orleans this is before pre Katrina those
who you're old enough remember Katrina
Katrina was was a devastating hurricane
that that had come and hit he said I
knew a a a Pakistani family in the area
that had a luxury car dealership in New
Orleans in New Orleans they had a luxury
car dealership and they used to trade
high value CS since it was a private
dealership meaning it wasn't a a name
brand dealership or you know with a big
company most of their cars they bought
almost everything they bought was a cash
deal they would pay for the cars cash
and the cars would come and they would
have them parked and they will sell it
and everything they had was or the
dealerships they had were by the by the
water area and when Katrina comes of
course it floods so all of their cars
get flooded and the business is
destroyed from top to top to bottom and
the person who's telling the story says
that they were earning pre Katrina this
is a safe estimate they were earning a
quarter of a million dollar on monthly
basis from their dealerships so it was
not a small business they were they were
doing
well the the the the the hurricane comes
the family Escapes in one vehicle that's
all they have left everything has been
wiped
off and when when the city opens back up
they make their way back into into the
town and of course now they cannot
rebuild because everything they had is
complet completely done for all the
money they had was invested in the cars
it's completely
gone so the the there was a person
another person in the community who had
a pizzeria and then the family decided
to go work for them the father and the
mother worked in the pizzeria while the
son used the same car to deliver food
Pizzas around town so the the the the
the the the scholar is telling the story
he says I went back to visit them and
and he said I was shocked at the
condition they were living in and he
said I wanted to talk to to them and
understand what were they going through
so he said you know when I had a time I
sat down with the father and I said how
and he said before I finish the sentence
the the the father had a big smile on
his
face and he said I know what you're
going to ask me how are we getting by
how are we living now everything has
been taken away from
us he said yes I want to hear it he says
look you know we had a couple of
dealerships before there was always
problems I was busy on the phone this
car didn't happen that car broke down
this guy didn't deliver the deliver is
late this guy is asking for money back
this guy's asking for this employee
didn't show up he said I barely made it
to my jum he said now I get there early
enough and I have time to pray myah and
he said and by the way the the person
telling the story says this guy's Elder
in the age so he's not a young man
anymore you know all of his life he's
worked on this and now it's been taken
away and he said and in his last
statement was the most important thing
that struck me he said Allah subhana
tala gave me an opportunity at the end
of my life to get myself closer to
him if this end of the
Ayah does not strike you with that I
don't know what else strikes with
you because we're seeking we're all
seeking
something security peace
tranquility a bigger house a better car
a better job more money
more
business I really feel quoting you
know a rapper but I don't want to do
that now but because then you know it
gets a little funny but but here's
here's what it is we're chasing chasing
chasing after something that has no
guarantee of existence or changing my
life into for the better of it if I got
it now pay attention to the next Ayah
that follows that Ayah and I think this
is the most Cru part that we need to
imprint in our heads what Allah
says Allah says and by the way they did
not understand how Allah himself is
supposed to be
worshiped and there's another Ayah that
has the same
beginning
Allah that's a different ay but same
same concept he
says they did not fulfill their due to
Allah subhana tala in the manner that
he's supposed to be
worshiped and that's our
weakness that's our weakness as a human
being I show up to a particular Salah or
I'm in the Masid for five Salas because
I have troubles in my life and then the
trouble gets taken care of and then my
time in Masid or my time with Allah
starts going
away you know f is minus you know is
minus J oh brother you know I got a job
now I can't come I have to do this Allah
was taking care of you before when you
didn't have a job either you were still
okay you were still eating you still
survived but now that he blessed you
with having a means now it's a
tradeoff I'm not going to attend
because I have a
job you know in U there's a there's a
there's a couple of you know and I'll
say this and once again you know I hate
translating poetry you you see I already
see you some of you laughing already
because you already know the story I say
that every single time I say poetry a
butcher it if there is Arabic poetry you
translate in English it butchers it if
it's uru poetry you translate it to
English it butchers
it you
know you know that the poet
says and he says you know what is what
is the heart I have I would have
penetrated your soul but you didn't love
me the way I deserve to be
loved right
right you know that the heart he says
you know forget about the heart I would
have penetrated your soul but you didn't
love me you didn't you didn't honor me
in the manner it was supposed to be
honored and that's the condition we're
in we're always seeking and it's okay to
seek but that bond with Allah is getting
weaker how is it getting weaker Ya Allah
if you exist you are you are the
most strong
why is this
happening we don't know that and part of
that is we don't know as a human being
we don't know the of Allah
subhana but that does not mean that we
forget about and pack it
up you know go on any page that is
discussing the issue or has the pictures
or the videos most comments underneath
are if Allah existed this would not
happen Allah is telling you
you the one that's seeking and what
you're seeking after are both
weak because what happens when your Iman
is strong what happens and let's try to
wrap it up inshallah cuz time is
escaping me what happens when that bond
is strong from Allah subhana tala you
know it it mentions in the in the in
thei I'll mention the the the the
reference and you guys can look at up
it
is the the patient patient book is
mentioned it mentions that wasallam said
the believer is that of a tender plant
which when the wind bends it it
bends and then other times it goes back
up
straight right an example of a hypocrite
is of a pine tree which keeps straight
pointing Towards the Sky till
once the strong wind comes and all of a
sudden it's completely gone it's top
a so that's the thing and then part of
that that that having the faith in Allah
subhana tala part of that having the
Trust In Allah subhana tala is
understanding
that the most important deal that Allah
has made with us and this is the most
important deal inah TBA Ayah number 111
Allah subh has already told
us Allah subhana tala has already
purchased from Believers their
money and
themselves so they can have what the
paradise that's it Allah has already
made that transaction
happen now the choice is ours either we
go into the transaction willingly or
unwillingly and if you go into a
transaction willingly Allah Allah
subhana tala mentions in the end of the
Ayah indeed that is the
triumphus the most Supreme reward that
you can
have Allah is already made that
transaction and let me finish with this
let me finish the first part with
this I've said this before in private
conversations and I say this again out
loud people our brothers and sisters
from that part of the world are chosen
ones Allah has chosen
them they have chosen them
as the story that happened about the
young child where the King was throwing
people into into fire for believing and
the mother hesitated because she had a
small child with her who was still
suckling at her and she hesitated in a
in a second to to disbelieve and save
herself and the child not herself for
the child the child speaks out and by
the way for those CH for those who
pay attention in the in the in the
Islamic history in in in the theology
this was one of the Childs who
spoke you know from they were the
infancy they could not speak they spoke
out and he says and the child says to
the mother do not do not hesitate Allah
has Jenna ready for us let's go jump
jump in that
fire I ask Allah subhana tala to make us
from those people to make us from this
people that he puts in their heart that
there is no rescue accept the rescue of
Allah subhana
tala for Allah subhana tala has told us
if everybody gathered against you nobody
can save you except for
Allah we ask Allah subhana tala to
relieve the burden on our brothers and
sisters who are suffering through these
atrocities and and genocides and murders
and looting and pillaging may Allah subh
reward them in the highest and give them
the fos
whose roof is the of Allah
[Silence]
subh
alhamdulillah alul
I want to mention a Dua
of it's a who used to make a Dua it's
mentioned when he used to read Salah his
Salah had a lot
of is somebody who has not
seenam himself with his own eyes when he
had Faith or she had Faith but he has
met the sahabah who have
seenam so it's a Dua that I was
introduced to by by Mas and it's and
it's amazing Dua if if we can remember
it inshallah it's good if not I'll I'll
translate it Dua he
[Silence]
says so this this this man this Pious
man is reaching out to Allah subhana
tala and he says yaah Allah you created
me by your
will you created me out of your will Ya
Allah I did not ask to be born so to
speak and then you made sure that I was
born in a time in an era that had the
these difficulties it had all these
troubles that I'm going through all
these things that are happening around
me I didn't choose to be born in this
era I didn't choose to have these issues
surrounding
me and then you told me to hold on to
rope of Allah subhana
tala so you told me to hold on to the
Rope of Allah and he says
you know those words are so beautiful W
he says Ya Allah how can I hold on to
your Rob if you do not Aid me in holding
all to your rope Ya
Allah understand as a human we are
weak everything around is weak yes I
understand that I understand that there
is a political solution and we should be
going and voting and we should be
calling our our our state senators and
representativ all that yes those are
part of it but there is another part of
it that you're supposed to be following
the script for and that's this
part this is this part right here that
we are so
weak we ask Allah subhana tala to
deliver our brothers and
sisters from the pain and the suffering
that is
happening Ya Allah Lord of heavens and
the Earth we turn to you in humility and
Desperation asking for your mercy and
Aid Ya Allah ease the suffering of our
brothers and sisters in lebnan Grant
them patience and strength and
resilience in these trying times Ya
Allah protect their homes their lives
their families turn away their press and
Grant Victory through your pressed Ya
Allah raise from among themselves
leaders who will guide them to wisdom
strength and Justice send them your Aid
Ya Allah as you aided the Believers in
the past unite our hearts as a umah to
stand in solidarity with them Ya Allah
forgive us for our shortcomings in
helping our Muslim fellows brothers and
sisters and grant us strength and
courage to do more Ya Allah soften our
hearts of those in power so they may act
in compassion and bring end to this
Bloodshed Ya Allah we ask you for peace
in festine in lebnan in Sudan and
Muslims suffering everywhere we ask for
justice for the oppressed and
accountability for the oppressed Ya
Allah Grant the martys of this umah the
highest ranks in the Jenna and heal the
wounded and brokenhearted Ya Allah Allah
subhana tala ordered himself to do this
act and he ordered his Mala to do this
act Allah subh T has told us to send in
peace and blessings on on his prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
[Silence]
allahar allahar
allahar ill
strain your lines fill the gaps in
between may Allah have mercy upon us if
you have mobile devices on you please
make sure the ringers are
off
Allah ald
Al
[Silence]
amen for
ahbar
Allah allahar
[Silence]
allahar allahar
allahar alhamd
[Silence]
amen
allar
[Silence]
allahar
allahar allahar
[Silence]
allahar
on
[Silence]
announcements
so
inah there is a fundraising coming up
that's going to be part of the the a to
inshallah if you guys are interested
there's some folks in the back who will
talk to you inshallah about that
besides that inshallah we're we're good
in we'll try to have a after thoughts
tonight so if you have some questions or
or discussions you want to forther talk
about inshallah address tonight asley on
the way out